because I've been listening to the Sam
Harris discussion with Jordan they keep
leaking if you guys want I could if you
haven't seen that I can give you the
links and so the last one in Dublin
leaked again and you know Sam Sam keeps
saying like he does want to recover
something like he wants to recover
ritual he wants to recover attention and
and beauty and story and all that but
it's like just he just doesn't like the
fact that he can't believe in the things
scientifically for some reason like that
somehow he doesn't want to believe in
what he calls [ __ ] stuff right yeah
that's because he's a fundamentalist
that's what it no I'm serious he is
there's a conversation if you listen to
Sam and his podcast he did a
conversation with Eric Weinstein where
Eric Weinstein basically makes him admit
that the reason why he's like that is
because if he was religious he would be
a fundamentalist it's a pretty amazing
discussion actually and he may and Eric
once that actually makes him visit the
places in his mind where he can imagine
himself as a as a Taliban or as a you
know as an Isis fighter and Sam he
basically says that yes he does have
that in him he actually has sympathy for
for Isis he has sympathy for for the
further the the fundamentalist type
religious person and that's why in a way
he's kind of fighting that because he
doesn't see he struggles to see another
way to be to be religious or he
struggles to see a hierarchy in religion
he struggles to see that you know you
know the the Saints the the fathers the
scholars of the church have never
believed in these things in the same way
that the peasant believed in them but he
didn't spend his time trying to debunk
with the peasant thought because that's
there's no purpose in that because
there's a hierarchy in in this stuff and
he he does
mind that the peasant thinks of it in a
very very crude and very you know
immediate let's say non non filtered way
or whatever whatever you want to see it
because it doesn't matter if it has the
same effect you will do they'll never
stop arguing about super its position
how should you read those things and
there's people were like I think there
are people that were extremely gated or
mean like tortured or whatever because
of the way they saw the book there's
just so much hard imitation there and
the only stinky you will get become
Memphis and not people I know and it's
an it to me I mean to me it's the most
infuriating and I think it's also one of
the one of the kind of frustrating
things to me is you always wish you
could be there and like oh like I wish I
could say this because you know even in
the last word discussion in Dublin you
know Sam starts talking about you know
it's always this idea that that we don't
have kind of this secular extremism you
know and it's like what are you talking
about I mean even the French Revolution
was exactly that I keep thinking you
know because he talks about how he wants
to keep attention and ritual and all
this stuff and I said you know they
tried to do that during the French
Revolution they tried to create a
religion of reason and they had like the
goddess of Reason and they tried to to
have they had processions and they had
all this and that was and it happened in
mired in blood like it happened soaking
in the blood of the Catholic peasants
who refused to participate in their
sacrilege and so it's like during the
French they found they found in the
South of France they
found entire churches that were that
were burned down with people inside the
church you know hiding from from the the
the revolutionary soldiers because they
went they wouldn't submit you know and
and people they found the corpses of
people holding on to their rosaries you
know hundreds of people just burned down
by by these soldiers it's like what do
you mean you know and it feels like he
has such a naive vision he has such a he
has such a twisted vision of history
which makes it so that he can say that
whatever it is that he wants to do it's
never been tried and that's always a
really nice place to stand in right it's
like well you know no one's ever done
this before and if they did it it would
be awesome like there would be no
problems and everybody would love each
other and everybody is like you you you
you know and you know and you see that
with Protestants to Protestants have
that same thing it's like they split off
the church and then they feel like they
can just take the backpack of all the
sins of Christianity off their back and
say well that wasn't us like oh no we're
we're we're a clean slate we're fine
we're good like we just follow the Bible
and we're doing our thing it's like you
know you have to keep that backpack on
it's like I want to put I want to keep
on my back all the horrible things that
Christians did all the all the
Inquisition's all that I want that in my
backpack I don't want to take it off
because if I do then I'm gonna do then I
there's way more chance that I'm gonna
do it again because I'm naive and I
don't understand it it's just it's just
part of human nature to to engage in
those kinds of things you know it's like
I'm sure that it's not Sam Harris that
that will be that'll be burning down
churches I'm sure it's not him but he's
not the one but if we if we Institute
his program it's gonna be other people
they're gonna do it it's gonna be other
people that are going to be doing it you
know that's why that's what I think and
it's the same with like that's why one
of the reasons why we have kind of this
weird social justice extremism it's just
because it's taken up all the space in
society it's taking up so much space in
society that those types of people that
are extremists in their nature that's
just what they are it's people now
they've taken on that they've taken on
that mantle did you see what I'm saying
like it could be any
it could be anything there always be a
some people in society that are
extremely narrow minded and extremely
kind of you know action oriented and and
you know us them mentality and those
people will take up whatever is there
that's right and there's always an
opening for crazies cuz that's just just
how that's just how it is
anyway so did you have you have you
listened to it and you listened to the
one in Dublin yet I think there is like
you said there were points in the first
one when I listened to it one only two
because there are moments when I want to
say something I know you wish you could
just think like like button like what I
just told you earlier about that that
Samaras doesn't think you can from the
beginning and there's been it's like
it's like no one has ever agreed on
everything and and then the whole thing
it's so weird like the whole thing about
finding some weird law in in leviticus
about stoning about stoning your son
whose disobedience like no one does that
no one Jews don't do that Christians
don't do that it's like we're what weird
like I don't know and they haven't done
that for 2,000 years
like seriously 2,000 years like Jews
even who follow the law haven't been
doing that for at least 2,000 years and
so I don't know like I seriously I don't
know where anyways